Final Fantasy explorers is a mash-up of
Final Fantasy elements built within the
framework of creature tracking games
such as Monster Hunter
however the seemingly endless march of
quests can get repetitive and sometimes
tedious and the economy is frustrating
but the fanservice is so pure it's
almost too sweet
Final Fantasy explorers succeeds in
creating an MMO light that sorry for the
cliche fans of the series will adore
there's no real plot to explorers but
that doesn't matter because you're here
to fight stuff and it's not missed you
can switch job classes and your loadout
at any time and explorers encourages you
to try them all because each has its own
unique weapons and abilities weapons
also retain their own combat styles with
significant differences and as you gain
experience you can purchase more
powerful versions of your jobs abilities
I spent a lot of time running around
with clouds Buster Sword then got bored
and became a geomancer then finally a
dragoon it's like getting a chance to
re-roll an MMO character without penalty
to your progression quests are all the
same fight fiends get paid environments
look similar and there isn't much
variety here but what they lack in looks
quests make up for with some truly epic
boss battles
the in favorite summons like Shiva III
and Ramu return as a Dolan's magical
beings that pack a lot of punch early
game quests don't pose much of a
challenge but battles become more
complicated and challenging later on
it's worth grinding out some sub quests
so you can contend in these more
tactically interesting battles and score
rare crafting items so you can forge fun
armor sets like crystalline dragoon
armor or Sephiroth's coat rewards
include crystal points and gill crystal
points are used to purchase new
abilities and upgrade equipment whereas
Gil buys new items better drop rates and
monster companions but you need to pay
Gil to start quests and some of these
costs up to ten thousand Gil I'm not a
fan of having to pay to progress
especially because Gillis sparse in your
earnings it's frustrating having to
weigh between progressing the story or
buying new equipment you can solar run
all of explorers but it's better with
friends if you don't have any you can
use a monster captured on your
adventures these monsters AI is pretty
smart and sometimes stupidly effective I
can't tell you the number of times my
chocobo his name is Pablo pecked an
enemy to death while I recuperated
filling up such powerful companions is
satisfying in the real world you can
play with up to three others or one or
two others in your favorite monster
heading in to fight through the team in
complementary combat roles as a
satisfying tactical exercise but the
best part is that you all get the same
number of reward items as there are
players however you can only complete
quests and locked by the least
accomplished player meaning if you're a
high level you may have to double back a
bit and pull them through it kind of
feels like destiny
with Final Fantasy explorers I kept
coming back for the fanservice the sheer
number of quests and the complexity of
customization will keep you busy for
hours if you like that sort of thing and
even though its economy leaves a bit to
be desired it wasn't clunky enough to
dissuade me from working hard for the
money and the sefirot suit because while
Final Fantasy explorers isn't a true
Final Fantasy game in a sense it still
hits the sweet spot by sending you into
a strange new world against egg nificent
creatures and impossible odds
you